TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everybody.
Thank you.
I have a cheering section.
That's amazing.
How's everybody doing?
Having a good I/O?
Just got a few more
sessions to go.
I'm glad that you made
it out to this point.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is Ubiquitous
Computing with Google.
Now, we've all been
talking a lot lately
about ubiquitous computing,
IOT, wearables, and so on.
And there's a lot we're going
to be able to do together
to help make our users'
relationship to technology
better.
And this is the next step.
Before I get
started, please know
that you can give me feedback.
The I/O overlords
would like to know
what you think of this
and similar content
and this session in particular.
So just head over
to the schedule
either on the app or the web.
And tell us what you think.
OK.
So a year ago, I stood on
this or a very similar stage.
And I talked to you about
wearable computing with Google.
I put forth this
idea of computing
that was more about the
user than the device
that they carried.
And we explored the implications
of that and code design
by looking at the
problem through NPC,
simple and straightforward,
thinking about the space.
Today, we're going to take
those ideas and build upon them.
In this session, we're
going to take a deeper look
at the platforms
and tools that can
make your app available on
a variety of form factors,
not just across wearables,
but something that's available
on your television and
in your car and someday,
even more places.
And we'll explore the
implications of that design
through code that you can
check out and compile today.
Let's get started.
So first off, what is
ubiquitous computing?
It's simply a fancy
phrase for technology
that's accessible to the user
whenever and wherever they
want or need it.
That's it.
It could be outside when
they're going for a bike ride
or having some friends
over to watch cat videos.
Or maybe it's time
for a road trip.
Your users can be in
any of those situations.
And you don't want them to have
to think about what device they
need to get to your service.
Instead, you're going to want an
experience that presents itself
to the user wherever
it makes sense
by building an app that
runs on whatever device
they have nearby.
And many people look at
the evolution of computing
like this.
It's always about the next
device-- big computer,
little computer,
littler computer.
What's the next thing in
this linear progression?
But really, our
present and future
looks quite a bit different.
It looks a lot more
like this, right?
We use a bunch of technology
in different ways.
And we often do
that simultaneously.
In fact, the growth of
these connected devices
is staggering.
Although the number
in 2020 depends
on who you ask-- it can be
a little bit different--
It's always more
than you can imagine.
Now, I didn't throw
out the units here.
Does anybody want to tell
me what the units are there?
Millions?
It's billions.
200 billion devices in 2020.
And you can actually break this
number down because 200 billion
is sort of like this
abstract number.
Think of it this way.
26 smart devices for every
human on the planet in 2020.
A lot.
But not everybody has 26 in
their pockets at the same time,
right?
This is across industries.
But think about the number of
devices that are going to be
and already are in our world.
Here's another number for you.
Hey, this is really interesting,
especially for us, right?
Gartner has estimated
half of IOT solutions
will be from startups
less than three years old.
Half.
So the question really is,
have you already started
building for this reality?
The good news is it's not that
hard to deal with, not as hard
as it might seem.
The explosion in form factors
is manageable by having
a strong core platform that
lends itself to extensibility.
So you can think less about a
new project for each new device
and more about a
versatile solution
that you can extend
for new form factors
as they become available.
And these platforms that
help you, they exist today.
I'm going to show you a
working example in a bit.
But before we dig
into some code,
this is what it
looks like logically.
Now, the traditional approach
to supporting different devices
is to make an app for
each device and platform
as they become available
and adopted by users.
Like my animation?
This has typically
meant a new project
for each and every device
developed and supported
independently.
Just crazy.
And the ironic thing is that
we as developers are already
thinking about this
experience as part
of a single whole experience
for the user across devices.
It's just silly to approach
these as separate projects.
Instead, you want to take
the longer lens view.
Think about having a view
into your service from each
and every device
that makes sense.
Your model and controller
are on a central device
or in the cloud.
But then the wearable,
in the living room,
in the car's a different
view into that service.
And this is the definition
of ubiquitous computing
again, right?
It's where your
service is available
anywhere and everywhere.
Now, each of you
and your service
is going to differ
slightly, right?
It's going to look a little
bit different on the wrist
than it will in the car.
And that's what you want
to spend your time on.
You don't want to have to
spend your time on figuring out
the glue in between
all these things.
So what we'll do is we'll
jump right into best practices
here so that we can think
about how to conceptualize
that experience.
And people no longer
need to sit at a desk
to get the benefits
of technology.
Experiences that we build
can do more than just
allow for that usage, right?
As I've been saying, they
can assume that usage
throughout the day
and in the world.
They can do more
than just work nicely
with existing
technology in our lives.
They can work seamlessly
across all of it.
Now, with that in mind,
these best practices
will help us navigate the
issues, big and small,
that we develop in this way.
And a note about
these best practices
is that they're
guidelines that apply
to your experience
on each device
as well as the greater
experience across all devices,
which is a great litmus test
for best practices in this area.
And make them great for
ubiquitous computing
when you're thinking
about both the smaller
picture and the bigger
picture across everything
at the same time.
The first one is sort
of obvious, simple.
Now, think about it this way.
The user experience
should be so simple
that it feels effortless,
almost magical.
In the long run,
users always prefer
simplicity and reliability
over quantity of features.
Whatever user problem
you solve, make
sure to address
that really well.
And never get in the
way of that solution.
A great example of this
is a messaging app.
I love messaging
on Android Wear.
I get a message.
And I can reply by voice.
It's so intuitive and simple.
It just makes sense.
The next one is contextual.
Now, being contextual is
really about being relevant.
Take into account the time, the
location, and even the activity
the user's involved
in to provide them
with the most useful experience
wherever they happen to be.
As an example, I love the
idea of a shopping list
that automatically comes
up as I get into the store
and, before I leave, maybe sends
me a notification of any items
I might have missed.
In this case, we're providing
information to the user
before they have to
ask because we're
taking into account their
context for them, which
leads me to this idea.
The experience should be so fast
that it should feel immediate.
Now, being contextual
can help with this.
But it's also about
micro-interactions.
Remember that you're not
trying to distract and occupy
the user.
You want to present just
the right information
right away so they
can get what they need
and keep living their lives.
A great example of this is
Voice Search on Android TV.
The user can say what
show they want to watch.
And any app that's
set up for search
can launch that
content for them.
Another great example
is Auto Play and queuing
on Google Cast.
The next episode can
just come right on
so the user doesn't
have to stop and find it
when they're binge watching.
I do on the weekends.
The last thing is extensible.
And you're going to
want to build your app
and experience to be as
extensible as possible.
Where are the places
that your user will want
to user service in the future?
And how can you build
that into your core app
now so that the overall
experience that the user has
is in hand whenever and wherever
it makes sense for them?
So those are them.
Oh, an example of this-- music.
I love listening to
music wherever I want.
And it turns out, I think,
everybody's that way.
That might be at home
in the living room.
That might be on the go while
I'm on a run or in the car.
So there you are-- a
handful of principles
to help you refine the design
of your user experience
and reach your users in
an undeniably useful way.
That's really key.
We found when working
with developers
that these guidelines help the
most when working with new form
factors, understanding
right away how
to contextualize and measure
your work for success.
And that's why we created
a design sprint technique
for learning the design
principles for new form factors
in particular.
The material for one
of these design sprints
was just launched
yesterday morning
on developers.google.com.
And many of you who
arrived a session early
may have found a play
book on your seat.
Design sprints are a great
way to learn immediately
and to try out design principles
for these new form factors.
And then you can apply
them to your own project
with the comfort of familiarity.
All right.
Let's look at a practical
solution, shall we?
One that you can
download, compile, adjust,
and learn from.
A sample code usually just
shows you a narrow view
at a partial solution,
which is great
if you want to know just
how one thing works.
However, when you want to see
how everything fits together,
you need a fully
functioning example.
And this is particularly
important for building
across devices because how
everything fits together
is the thing.
And we recently released a
simple but complete app just
for this purpose.
This is not the
only kind of thing
that you can build
to be ubiquitous.
Remember that.
But rather, it's just a
look at one kind of app
and how it can be built
with these ideas in mind.
The universal
Android Music Player.
Remember I was just talking
about listening to music
everywhere?
This app helps you do that.
And it works on your phone,
your watch, your television--
both Android TV soon and Google
Cast-- and of course, your car.
And it's completely
open source on GitHub.
There's the URL.
Now, let's say you
have a media app that's
built around an activity.
This is pretty common.
And that was just fine
for an app on a device.
But if you want to support more
devices, what you usually do
is you either expand
that activity,
or you create new ones
for each new device.
That's still not so bad until
you realize that you probably
have to revisit your
app's overall design each
and every time to coordinate
new message passing, play
locks, and that kind of thing.
Instead, you're going to want a
solid core central service that
extends easily to
each new form factor.
There's an Android API that
makes this straightforward.
UAMP is built around this
media browser service and media
session.
So this is a way that you would
build your app on Lollipop
so that you could have media
keep playing in the background,
be controlled from the
lock screen, and so forth.
It's also a great way to
allow multiple devices
to act as consumers
of a central service
rather than everything built
in activities that need
to independently coordinate.
The media browser service
maintains a tree structure
of all your media, such
as a collection of music.
And this could be either
streamed or stored locally.
Media Session tracks
the current state
of what your app is playing.
Now, here's where
it gets interesting.
Everything, whether
it's your phone app,
Android TV, Android
Auto-- they're
all consumers of the Media
Browser Service and Media
Session.
Let's say you've got
your phone hooked up
to Android Auto like this.
So the companion app
on the left, that's
the Android Auto Companion app.
And that app is responsible
for drawing the user interface
and sending those pixels
to the vehicle display.
This app also connects to
the Media Browser Service.
And it queries it to
get the tree structure
of your apps media library.
The driver of the car
then selects the song,
either the touch screen
or through voice search,
and then Android Auto
will use Media Session
to run your callbacks.
And this is great on Android
Auto because as a developer,
you never have to worry
about the details of making
a user interface that's
safe for driving.
Android Auto takes care
of all of that for you.
It just needs the music service
available to get the data
and handle playback.
And the app on the left,
it could be anything.
It could be Android Wear .
It could be just another
activity in your same app
handling Android TV.
Or maybe it's
handling Google Cast.
Any of these will work
because of how it's set up.
We don't have to rewire the
app each and every time we
add a new form factor.
Instead, we have this
solid central service
that extends easily to
each new form factor.
You simply access
the music service
for any context that
makes sense for your user.
Now, remember what
I said earlier.
This is certainly
not the only way
to make a ubiquitous app or
the only ubiquitous app that
makes sense.
It simply gives
you an idea of how
to structure a common
app such as a music
player for extensibility.
The specific APIs
you use are of course
going to depend
on your use case,
how you implement the best
practices we talked about,
and where you keep your
model and your controller.
It could be on the phone.
It could be in the cloud.
It could be wherever that
make sense for your service.
Let's take a look at
a few examples of apps
shipped and available
to users that are
doing this kind of thing today.
iHeartRadio-- it brings radio,
music, news, podcasts, sports,
and more to users.
And you can even make
your own custom stations.
It's easy to use.
And it's free.
I love this app.
And best of all--
my favorite thing--
it's available wherever I go.
It's on Android Wear.
You can Cast to your TV.
You can even use it in the car.
Another great app is
WhatsApp messenger.
It's great for messaging,
sending photos,
group chat, and a lot more.
And it's been available for
phones for a long while.
And it's also available on
Android Wear and Android Auto.
Do you see the pattern here?
This is one of those
applications like music
where you expect it
to work everywhere.
And it does.
You can keep the conversation
going whether you're
waiting in line with your phone,
on a walk with your watch,
or a quick road
trip with your car.
And last, Cookbook.
Cookbook aims to bring users
the joy of cooking and sharing
with Recipe Search,
calculated prep time, shopping
list, and more.
And if you're like me, you
like to get everything as messy
in the kitchen as
possible, which
is great because it works on
all the things I can get messy.
It works on the phone.
You can also load your recipes
up on your watch or your TV,
as well.
Now, if you'd like to do
with your app what these apps
have done.
you can find a lot more detail
on the Ubiquitous Computing
course that's launching on
Udacity in the coming weeks.
It's part of the
Android Nano degree.
And it's going to be
available very soon.
It covers wearables,
living room,
and auto in much more detail
than we talked about today.
There's an old
saying that I keep
coming back to when we're
thinking about this space.
Sometimes, when building
apps-- and we're
all guilty of this--
we forget to see
the forest for the
trees, which is to say,
we get so focused on that
one thing in front of us
that we forget
that we're building
a relationship with the
user across their lives,
across their technology.
And to be really valuable, we
should be present in their life
whenever it makes sense to them.
To this end, we should
build with ubiquity in mind
from the beginning and extend
to new form factors over time.
And the tools and
design knowledge
that are required for
this are available.
And they're at your fingertips.
We just need to get started.
And then we're going to find
out how much further we can go.
For example, the Works
with Nest program
is making the potential of
the thoughtful home real.
You can learn more
on their website.
Also, announced yesterday
was project Brillo.
This is an operating system
for the internet of things.
It's derived from Android
and able to run on devices
with a minimal footprint.
Core functionality
includes connectivity
and scaled management.
And of course, when
you pair with Weave,
also talked about yesterday,
setup and discovery
becomes effortless for the user.
And devices can
all be compatible
and work with each other.
This is the future
of what we do.
And we should get together.
And we should talk
about it more.
So also announcing today,
we're going to do just that.
I hope you can join us
for first conference
on ubiquitous computing
as we get together
as friends across
companies and industries
to work towards more
interoperability and ultimately
more value for all of our users.
Please head to this
link to sign up
and be the first in
line to hear more.
And if you like,
let us know what
you want from this conference.
Maybe you want to speak.
Or maybe there's another way
you want to get involved.
Let's build this together.
Please dive in and learn
so that you can reach
your users in even more places.
And we can really start to have
a deep conversation about all
these things.
Now, over here in
the area to my right,
you'll see all these people
in lovely red shirts.
We're actually going
to be taking Q&A
as a group out in the sandbox.
We hope you join us there.
We can play with devices.
We can talk about
your specific apps.
And we can really engage
in a conversation right out
in the sandbox.
Thank you very much.